monday morning what's driving me crazy
how about a follow-up to a driving you
crazy email chain that started during
the pandemic when i was broadcasting in
my living room from the bowtie nate home
studio
a mystery bridge at the 95 and grand
teton we got an email from viewer
patrick who wrote we live just off
osablanc and grand teton six years ago
we were told a bridge was in the plans
over the 95 to grand teton on the east
side of the freeway is this ever going
to happen fast forward to may of last
year well we got another email from
viewer deborah who writes hey do you
have any idea when that bridge might be
started or finished or if the project is
just scrapped forever in that same
report the city updated the federal
money to build the overpass is now
available to begin the project but they
had to do an environmental study now
fast forward again to march of this year
with another update from the city
they're now hopeful that both the nevada
department of transportation and the
federal highway administration will sign
off on required environmental studies in
june well that must have worked because
even though a bridge connecting grand
teton over the 95 is still nowhere to be
found our original emailer patrick
checked back in a couple of weeks ago
the grand teton overpass the 95 has
finally started
the eight news now drone had to look
closely but yes the work is underway
yeah
so if the original 18-month work
estimate is still good the bridge might
be open by early 2024 so that would make
it an even 10
years from when patrick and his
neighbors were first told about the
project mystery almost solved we're
going to keep checking patrick deborah
city of las vegas thanks for riding
staying on top of this buckle up drive
carefully please put on the phone you
can join the drive and you crazy
conversation at traffic 8 8newsnow.com